now to the latest from El Paso Texas
where there's been a sudden jump in the
number of migrants seeking Asylum and
it's putting a strain on that City's
resources more than 2 000 people a day
are arriving at the border they're
asking to be processed and local leaders
are saying that that number is just
unsustainable why are they coming well
Lilia Luciano spoke with some of those
crossing the border
[Applause]
after an 18-day Trek spanning more than
2 200 miles you can see the
transformation in Ingrid Lopez's
expression as she takes account of what
her family has survived on the way here
and the sacrifices she and her husband
Wilson have made without work and
fleeing political persecution to offer
their 13 year old Emily a safe life
after Crossing several borders they
boarded a bus in Mexico with about 40
others but instead of the freedom to the
north they say the drivers delivered
them and hundreds of others into the
hands of armed kidnappers
the fear piled on locked in a warehouse
for days with more threats than food
praying to survive
starving they say the group managed to
escape by breaking down the doors and
running to a neighboring town for help
then her smile Fades remembering a
reality as cold as the crowded floors
they slept on at the immigration
processing center you felt that the
experience having been kidnapped by
these criminal organizations in Mexico
felt the same as when you finally
crossed and were detained
they were finally released and came to
this shelter as they make their way to
Baltimore to await their Asylum hearing
but with local shelters at capacity
others wait for those next steps in the
freezing cold what we're doing city
manager Tommy Gonzalez says the city has
already spent 9.5 million and needs
Millions more from the federal
government to shelter direct and were
needed transport migrants arriving here
all hands need to be on deck let's keep
the migrants needs in mind they're not a
project they're people
the city of El Paso just learned that
they will receive six million dollars
from FEMA for costs related to manage
the crisis and local officials tell me
they also hope that the federal
government will open for Bliss something
that's done before as a shelter as you
can see that is already needed and will
be desperately so in a week if title 42
expires Nate the cold is bone chilling
right now yeah the shelter is much
needed that's for sure Lilia thank you